so what do we want to see tonight in the
draft that's today's draft here's the
trivia question for chris sims if he
gets it right he gets the first pick joe
burrow is likely going to be the first
overall pick tonight if that happens he
will become just the second quarterback
in the common draft era to win the
heisman trophy and the national
championship the season before being the
first pick in the draft who was the
other player to do it chris
heisman oh my national championship
first overall pick
oh my gosh hold on this is i i i this is
so easy it's the common draft era you're
talking about right here so yes
oh my gosh who am i missing here
that's the heisman national championship
number one pick is this really obvious
am i stupid here like that yes that i'm
that i'm missing this one
who the hell is all right go ahead i'm
choking total choke cam newton i was
going to give you a hint cam newton i
mean i was going to say he's still in
the league sort of anything
like that would have told you yeah cam
newton all right damn
i can't believe i got that wrong or
didn't get a guess at all but but when
we say common draft then you start
thinking of guys like why a tittle and
bart star and you know if i went with
the last 10 years if if we had just said
in the last 10 years you probably would
have figured out cam newton all right uh
first pick for me very simple very easy
where does tuatangobyloa land that's
what i want to see that's the story of
the draft it's the johnny manziel
question
six years later and let me tell you the
2014 draft and i i saw that it was
re-aired last night the 2014 draft was
one of the most compelling that i can
remember simply because of johnny
manziel the free fall the cowboys the
intrigue the drama the browns getting
involved and making pick number 22. i i
don't know that the same thing is going
to play out with tua i i feel bad for
him if he slides but i kind of wanted to
slide chris cause i want it to last i
don't want him to go in the top five i
don't want him to go in the top ten i
want it to linger i want it to become
compelling and uh sorry to i know you
want to get drafted you want to get paid
but i want to be entertained and i'm
going to be more entertained the longer
he's on the board well yeah i mean i
hear you and
you know that's kind of where i wanted
to go with my first pick honestly it's
along the same line so that's a good one
you know i'm gonna say something similar
but it's not the same and the fact that
i i kind of want to see miami dolphins
you know not pick a quarterback with
their first two picks
and us be all in like oh my gosh what
are they going to do with pick number 26
you know
i just want to see the chaos of that so
that's going to be my first pick it's
just like i want to see the dolphins
pass on the quarterback with their first
two picks and then go oh man is two is
still going to be on the board are they
going to make a a late move to maybe
trade back up in like i said earlier in
the show and get a fourth pick in the
first round and get a guy like jordan
love or do they just take jordan love
with the 26 pick but that's to me the
one thing i i you know again i really
like justin herbert but just for viewing
pleasure
i would love to see that in the chaos it
creates and where this whole quarterback
conversation goes from there
next one for me and this one is very
simple and it's not will the
commissioner be booed it's how
will the commissioner be booed he teased
to peter king earlier this week that
basically you have to tune in to see
what happens and then there was a
promotion that came out from budweiser a
bud light bud light seltzer one of them
that you could do a video of yourself
booing the commissioner they were going
to contribute a dollar for every video
to coronavirus relief up to 500 000
which is a great cause a great reason to
do it so maybe they'll be playing some
of those videos but that's a little too
self-aware that's forced that's not
organic i want to know will there be
authentic organic actual booing there's
going to be a montage behind the
commissioner during every pick of 15
fans and i don't we talked about this
last week i don't think that's enough
anonymity to get them to naturally boo
him because you know if it's 10 000
people they'll boo and then when it's a
small group they'll clamor for selfies
and signatures that's the way the human
mind works but i i don't i don't know i
mean will they will they view this
promotion
to be enough or will there be some other
avenue for booing the commissioner i'd
love to see his family kind of just kind
of boom to get it all started if you do
it the right way you come off as getting
it and and i think he does kind of get
it there's a difference between getting
it though and coming off on tv as if you
get it if that makes any sense and it
probably doesn't
no it doesn't make any sense but i
understand
yeah i guess so okay but i mean i i did
the right yeah i would that would be
cool actually though if roger goodell is
about to get up there and all of a
sudden we see his wife and kids all of a
sudden go boo
you stink dad you stink that would be
really funny i actually would enjoy that
i hope he has i hope he has fun with it
it's kind of a tradition
you know and we need to hear some boo
with roger goodell at some point it's
and again like you said it's not it's
not personal people just like to boo
people of power more times than not uh
whether it's owners commissioners
whatever it may be all right and you
take them and you take that you take the
power away from the boo if you embrace
it you you turn it from an insult into
something that is not necessarily
positive but it's not as negative as it
otherwise would be yes exactly right i i
hear you there and that it will be cool
it'd be interesting to see what they do
maybe if they add some fake blues in
there or something like that um all
right i'm along a little bit of the same
lines here too my i want to see
a really crucial pick right
like it's about to go down there was
this huge trade and we're gonna finally
hear
who this team that made this big trade
for
and then i want the zoom connection to
freeze just as he's about to say the
name so we're all like wait who the hell
did it who is it and none of us know for
about like a minute until it gets
figured out or whatever it may be to me
that would just be fun and add a little
theatrics to it and of course the
reality of the situation is that crap
happens right now like me getting cut
off of the show a few times this week
already
yeah i would think you would have a
little more and i never know whether
it's sympathy or empathy i always have
to look it up or think about it but i
think you would be able to relate more
and and not want it to happen given the
stream of expletives that you let fly
during the break when you got cut off
multiple times earlier this week
yes well i do i have i have empathy or
sympathy towards that i do but it
doesn't mean i wouldn't want to see
somebody else stress out for a few
seconds for some entertainment and
especially just to like leave the whole
nation in the dark for just a few
seconds to where we're all like wait who
is it who did they pick what's wrong
with my tv why is it not working what
happened
i think that would be kind of fun you
know eventually we'll get to know who it
is i just want to see a little chaos
all right uh and chaos
chaos is normally good i just don't want
chaos to derail this process and i don't
think it will but but you know a glitch
or two here or there i think will make
some sense all right i want to see
whether or not lsu or alabama tie the
miami record for seven first-round picks
taken uh from the same school in the
same year it was 2004 for miami and i
mean
when all else fails pick somebody from
lsu or alabama it's the mike mayhawk
approach remember last year clemson in
alabama now it's lsu in alabama just
take a guy from lsu or alabama and
you'll be fine if you don't know what
else to do and i'm kind of hoping that
they both end up with seven guys in the
first round chris i i that was that was
going to be my next pick and i mean i'm
with you there it it it would be cool to
see one of those two teams break the
record i think alabama probably has a
better chance to break it than lsu but
regardless i mean it just once again the
sec
as we've seen there's just so much king
and foot in college football it's just
not even close between anybody else it
just all the sec sec players are what
they're they're looking here to break
the record again for the first round
with most most conference players
drafted so i hear you there um all right
i think i'm gonna go with something i
went with my mock draft and you know
it's a rumor that i heard from like i
told you that somebody i trust or two
people that i trust but i really want to
see it in a lot of ways i want to see cd
lamb go to the arizona cardinals to pick
number eight i think that will throw the
draft a big time curve ball i think it's
going to make a lot of teams panic and
the early teams who are looking at
receivers like maybe the jets the
raiders you know we've heard the broncos
are very interested at 15 at wide
receiver if one goes off the bar that
early i think you could see panic by
others that they thought they were going
to get a receiver that they really
wanted the teams to where they go oh no
maybe the guy we want might not be there
so that could lead one to some trades
but two cd lamb with kyler murray and
deandre hopkins and larry fitzgerald and
cliff kingsbury i just think would be
really cool it'd be like the
the golden state warriors offensive
explosion when they had kevin durant i
think it'd be fun for nfl
the rams are in real danger of getting
left in the dust in the nfc west because
they have become
all due respect dysfunctional or at
least borderline dysfunctional since
going to the super bowl and losing to
the patriots the other three teams in
that division all have that arrow
pointing up and the cardinals that they
get cd lamb uh they're gonna be real
real contenders in the division and in
the conference
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports